[Musique]
en direct du canada à l'heure de
montréal cette entame canada aujourd'hui
vendredi 6 septembre
aujourd'hui chanceuse puisque encore une
fois autour d'un thème nous avons de
nombreux collègues de radio canada
international et de différentes sections
qui se mélangent aux plaisirs du
vendredi parce que c'est ça aujourd'hui
l'émission c'est devenu ça c'est une
tradition depuis maintenant 12 ans le
vendredi on a du plaisir est bon de
marteau bonjour
samir ben jaafer oui bonjour stéphane
marie jobin et coûteuse est à chaque
fois que je parle de boules ya quelque
chose qui s'ajoute à votre tête
maintenant quand même là on va pas
commencer à avoir des propos qui
pourraient être mal compris alors les
labels qui tourne il vous me posez
toujours une excellente question
trois jeux par émission sans boule à
perdre à chaque jeu le nombre de boules
augmente
je vous avais géologue spécialiste des
réponses des bonnes réponses pour
souligner nos amis internautes que le
choix des couleurs aujourd'hui n'a pas
été conçu alors les trois gars satin
bleu et machin dont l'un avec la police
portuaire notre invité sera pas en bleu
[Musique]
ce qui porte leur semble beaucoup est-ce
que vous portez il pourrait y avoir
confusion un point quelconque du numéro
1 2 point
je viens de faire allégeance notre
invité qui s'en viennent à quelques
minutes à sur le sujet de la de
l'émission aujourd'hui vous n'avez
aucune idée de quoi on va parler
aujourd'hui examen vous nous cachez tous
je vous ai toujours par une vidéo 5
images et vous criez un peu comme eric
hall quand vous étiez petit vous avez la
bonne réponse vous levez la main
vous êtes le héros delà du match du
matin voici donc la vidéo
jusque là ça va alimentation ouest école
garderie quatre ans wayne sur la piste
quelque part sur la piste non non
l'exercice d'écriture dyslexie nord a
écrit apprendre apprendre ouidah oui là
il ya quelqu'un qui a passé ça va mal la
5éme images vous ne savez toujours pas
quelle était d'apprentissage
oui vous êtes vous là vous êtes à la
porte voilà voilà
parce que ce sujet ouais enfin le bout
oui vous avez deviné juste on va parler
avec quelqu'un d'allô prof mais je
voulais faire un petit test ici un peu
comme à l'école
c'est à l'école ils ont toujours leurs
tablettes téléphones cellulaires elop
on n'arrête pas le progrès là vous avez
l'autorisation d'utiliser vos tablettes
vos téléphones en classe a les idées moi
mon époque c'était de la triche risque
d'aller voir dans les livres ou des
téléphones même la documentation était
interdite pendant l'examen mais là il
fallait avoir étudié avance pour passer
l'examen
alors sa teinte est fait aide aux
devoirs dans un
un engin de recherche vraiment aller
lire un poème voix non ça ils nous
avaient pas n'avait pas payé assez cher
non d'accord alors servir lui ne veut
pas payer aussi maintenant c'est ce qui
ressort battu toria tutorat et attend de
voir cours d'été vous n'allez pas le
prof à vous attend alors non je suis la
petite erreur dans ma recherche
vous avez besoin d'aidé ou de voir à
dover domicile alors ça prouve au
tellement point vaut mieux avoir un pied
des zoreils ouais ouais
alors vous voyez il n'y a pas qu'à
l'adresse de voir où est ce un très bon
moment je ne recherche
il a besoin d'aller aux profs aussi le
tutorat chose que vos enfants pas besoin
d'être on y après pour notre première
premier jeu de la grosse boule maryse et
est prête à aller à des devoirs général
aux profs vous allez trouver un élément
en wallonie non non il y avait une
petite terreur de dans la recherche
écoutez voici la première question parce
qu'on parle des devoirs ce sera ça
peut-être une émission qui va devenir
très personnelle un moment donné vous
avez tous des enfants
oui vous aviez des enfants on a toujours
des enfants mais l'aide aux devoirs ont
eu la maîtrise du jeu
alors voici le céder à enquêter sur les
faits des devoirs sur la performance
scolaire dites moi quelle est sa
conclusion principale est ce que ca est
de voir comment ta performance de 5 à
15%
b et devoir revendre la performance de
15 à 25% ou c est de voir revendre la
performance de 25 à 35% ou s ed
aucune de ces réponses selon la tendance
actuelle c'est aucune de ces réponses
que se posent tous internes ans actuel
ça se passe avec les enfants veulent
pour faire chez moi c'est un combat
quotidien
mais là est ce qu'on parle des devoirs
au primaire au secondaire parce que je
me suis fait ça se termine sur quelque
chose c'est surtout aux primaires
françois puis vous vraiment ce sera ok
ne se met aucune différence m'arrive à
moi j'hésite entre a ou b parce que je
sais qu'au primaire c'est d'abord ce que
les enfants apprennent dans la classe
plutôt que ce qui se pratique à la
maison
bon me semble moi je dirais à g7 entre
je vais aller à des quartiers fait
prendre une grande chance dont et vous
avez raté l'examen à la bonne réponse
c'est ok je confesse un prix et le cd a
dit plus qu'on est jeune qu'on est jeune
la moins ça fait différence en fait
c'est vers le primaire secondaire
exactement vous n'avez pas tout à fait
alors faire une émission sur l'aide aux
devoirs alors que l'eau de ces liens ne
dit que dans l'ensemble on nous paye et
développer sa soeur pas grand chose
jusqu'à un certain point alors je vous
propose maintenant de nous tourner vers
notre spécialiste du jour il s'agit de
marc antoine tanguay directeur relations
extérieures et stratégies à l'autre à
bord du bleu et quand vous allez
remarquer je sors les grands esprits
sera encore le chef directeur vous êtes
donc bien jeune pour être directeur de
l'ot prof est ce que c'est vous qui avez
crié ça c'est probablement de travailler
avec des jeunes que fait que j'aie large
mais je suis plus taxes non j'ai pas
créé alors je me suis joint à l'équipe
qu'il ya quand même un petit bout de dix
huit ans maintenant mais elles n'ont pas
fait existe depuis 1987 c'était des gens
et services téléphoniques à l'est pas on
de développer beaucoup beaucoup sur
internet depuis c'est justement ça on
regarde leur coûte en train de regarder
les services des dos et j'ai remarqué
que c'était surtout dit des tuteurs des
gens qu'on en voyait chez chez les
enfants chez dans les familles ont peu
et ça coûte évidemment de l'argent
de l'autre côté c'est vous tablez sur
les nouvelles technologies c'est la
grande différence est ce que vous êtes
unique au canada qu'il faut passer par
votre site web pour recevoir l'ensemble
de vos services plus
oui exact c'est même une commande
jusqu'à jusqu'à l'année dernière il
ferait beaucoup de choses à travers le
monde
jusqu'à l'an dernier y avait pas de
propres et attire une espèce
d'écosystèmes de toutes les ressources
qu'on peut aller chercher pour répondre
à ces questions scolaires autant aux
primaires pour secondaire allô prof une
formule tu es vraiment une et où
effectivement un jeune ou un parent peut
aller chercher des contenus sur le site
internet ou communiquez carrément avec
des enseignants les points ce n'est pas
suffisant de juste consulter le site on
peut aussi poser des questions à des
vrais profs mais chute à guînes
c'est maryse jardin je voulais vous
demander est-ce que je puisse être
passés plus vers la technologie est ce
que ce sont davantage les parents qui
vous consulte que plutôt les étudiants
c'est un peu tout le monde en perte et
la technologie
ceci de merveilleux que ça nous a permis
de rejoindre beaucoup plus grand par une
plus vaste public
en réalité on était peut-être du nez les
lèvres jusqu'à la fin des années 90
début des années 2000 par année et l'an
dernier on en a et d du personnel babu
qui tient le genou le parent peut
trouver par lui même d'explications sur
le site internet par exemple visionner
une vidéo des points 3 4 minutes de
vidéo
on a finalement fait à répondre aux
problèmes qu'on avait et donc ça nous a
permis comme ceux de rayonner vraiment
beaucoup plus alors c'est autant les
parents que les enfants
mais c'est vrai que ces dernières années
est entré très populaire auprès des
jeunes on était les enquêtes et 90% des
élèves du québec connaît sa double coque
on s'est davantage tourné vers les
parents parce que les parents sont super
important l'éducation scolaire dans
l'investigation général
évidemment mais même au niveau de la
gamme is it à l'école et du désir
d'aller à l'école et de passer devant
des parents et grand rôle à jouer et on
s'adresse de plus en plus sûrs pour les
utilisent parce que finalement être
parent et accompagner son enfant
j'allais devoir que les études il avait
d'un éclat mais c'est pour quelque chose
qu'on apprend à l'école
quelque chose qu'on apprend tout sur le
top il ya des trucs qu'on leur donne
avait fait qu'on partageait les qu ils
soient mieux outillés monsieur tanguay
au monde des images de thierry karsenti
qui est un spécialiste dans le domaine
de l'éducation et de l'utilisation des
technologies
en éducation et lui il recommande
fortement les devoirs et mais à partir
d'un certain âge seulement au niveau
secondaire et je pense que là dessus il
ya consensus qui est en train de se
développer au niveau des spécialistes
qu'au niveau primaire c'est plus ou
moins utiles mais l'intéresse c'est
quand même au niveau primaire de montrer
qu on obliger les enfants à faire un
effort
quelques minutes parce qu'une fois
arrivé au secondaire s'ils ne savent pas
faire des devoirs ça peut compliquer
leur avenir
qu'est-ce que vous quels sont vos vue
là-dessus présentement exact en fait à
l'eau propre
on est là pour dépanner donner un coup
de main alors on n'a pas de nous ramène
pas d'effets sur la pertinence et de
vent en poupe et où des examens ou pas
parce que ce sujet sauf que bon on
répond aux besoins des jeunes donc c'est
pas un avis extérieur qu'on donne là
dessus par contre on est très au fait
des études sont évidemment et c'est vrai
que les mesures défirent sur les élèves
du primaire est plus limité il y aurait
un impact n'est pas assez important pour
pouvoir dire que on a gagné en
pourcentage je veux des primaires alors
que deux secondes à rui est ce que
monsieur karsenti mettait de l'avant
c'est effectivement un pur qu'il ya un
impact au secondaire
le fassois des gens un peu familiarisés
avec le cd devant une bande
d'entraînement mais qu'il faut limiter
dans le temps on se rend compte que si
tu as raison de la période de voir est
trop longue par rapport à l'âge de
l'enfant mais ont eu l'effet inverse
d'un enfant qui va peut-être se
décourager au moins aimé l'école est
motivé donc c'est un équilibre à trouver
et là tu dirais que c'est probablement
l'enseignant avec le parent qui sont les
mieux placés pour savoir selon la suite
un gain est ce que dans les études que
vous avez fait par rapport au clic sur
le site web
est ce qu'il y avait des demandes qui
viennent d'ailleurs que du québec
si on est à ce point sous l'eau sur le
marché dans la francophonie ailleurs
avec accès bien sûr web est ce que dit
clique qui font pour aller voir cette
bonjour instit c'est bien vu c'est vrai
que dans notre pays c'est plus la forme
buteur privé qui va la neige qui est
répandu effectivement on a beaucoup
beaucoup de fréquentation extérieur au
québec et au canada on parle de
plusieurs millions de visites de
l'extérieur
damman nous dans nos services on peut
pas communiquer avec un enseignant si on
n'est pas au québec parce que
l'enseignant sont rémunérés puis on les
garde pour que les québécois
maintenant qu'une vidéo qu'un exercice
lyonnais ou réalisés à l'étranger ça
nous rend si ça peut lire en 16 mai
effectivement au maroc en belgique dans
les pays francophones
or même en jeu juste par rapport aux
services que vous offrez les enfants qui
ont un peu de difficulté est ce que vous
les prenez en charge est ce que vous
savez ce qu'il ya un service ou un prof
pour ce genre d'élève
4 je peux expliquer un peu comment ça
fonctionne tout est gratuit
alors oui il ya un site internet on peut
consulter ventes pour l'ensemble des
contenus tout cela est gratuit et
d'élèves qui ensemble besoin de parents
d'élèves que communiquer avec
l'enseignante à l'épreuve ou un
professionnel mais aussi par exemple
nous orthopédagogue travail chez vous
pour répondre à n'importe quelle
question de n'importe quelle matière au
primaire et le secondaire
alors c'est vraiment solide et c'est que
filet de sécurité scolaire à tout le
monde au québec et on peut comme seul
s'assurer que les lèvres comprendre mais
pas sur un problème et il peut
communiquer avec l'enseignant par
téléphone par texto par cyber prof donc
sur le site internet directement dans
l'interface où on peut partager des
images de 6
des supports visuels supplémentaires et
nos enseignants sont accessible du lundi
au jeudi de 7 heures à 20 heures
c'est vraiment pendant la période des
devoirs parce que nos enseignants
travaillent dans les épaules de jo c'est
des drapeaux aux couleurs de cet os en
cadeau et de pouvoir comme ce sont des
questions des élèves
ça ne dérougit pas sécrété de profs
comme si d'adopter matière alors très
souvent un enseignant peut même se
tourner vers un collègue dans la
question est plus difficile des fois on
n'est pas des concepts ou non plus même
s'ils ont de quoi le travail en équipe
pour être sûr que les élèves sont des
métiers qui vont bien comprendre presque
gratuit pour l'usager comment ce qu'on
finance un service commun allô prof
allô prof reste études organismes de
bienfaisance et il est financé à moitié
par le ministère de l'éducation du
québec et l'autre moitié c'est il ya des
fondations des entreprises privées qui
veulent contribuer à la rive sud du
collège et le fonds finançant le service
donc nos enseignants la rémunération des
enseignants provient d'une tarification
à l'abandon complet de la cale élèves et
nos développements technologiques
on est beaucoup là-dedans sont au beau
coup financier puisque ma part des
entreprises et des fondations
il a aidé à explorer de nouvelles
avenues numérique au mieux répondre aux
besoins des élèves
et comme c'est en constante évolution
bien évidemment toujours en
développement
parler un peu plus tôt dié avant la
dernier on était unique au monde
est ce qu'il ya des jeux pas des
français de france qui frappent à la
porte en tant qu est ce que vous faites
là et qui se demandent comment illimité
parce que si vous répondez vraiment une
demande au québec je vois pas pourquoi
on répondrait pas également une demande
en france où est ce que vous pourriez
allô prof vous transporter en france et
peut-être ouvrir une multinationale de
bienfaisance mais bon c'est évidemment
marché francophone ou probablement pas
mal tout le pays
vraiment nos efforts sont concentrés sur
le québec et on sent qu'on a encore des
choses à faire ici avant de dire ok on a
fait le tour des formules qui ont
exporté vers l'avenir
par contre on a effectivement de
l'intérêt qu'ils manifestaient
d'apprendre la belgique de l'espagne
d'ici du canada et et on leur parle pas
ouvertement
qu'est ce qu'on fait après il n'y a pas
de pardon de structures similaires qui
ont été créés dans d'autres pays il ya
par contre par exemple l'initiative en
région aquitaine donc aborder il s'est
inspiré de notre service téléphonique
il ya quelque chose d'un peu équivalent
aussi à barcelone en ce moment ça c'est
des petits à droite à gauche qui sont
pas à locaux auraient fini si comme je
le disais un écosystème qui répond
vraiment à l'ensemble des besoins mais
il ya des députés sont sommés à droite à
gauche pour avoir dans les prochaines
années
on fait avec ça les clairement c'est pas
nous c'est un modèle dans lequel on
croit beaucoup à ce que l'on pensait que
ont produit énormément contenu de
qualité nos enseignants donnent kaman
une excitation au niveau très
professionnels aux élèves et on assure
saad membre en étant gratuit c'est notre
conception multiplication à nous allons
vérifier le corps c'est surtout le
congrès pour tous les états maintenant
chaque pays a ses réalités
on sonne comme on propose au musée
tinguely pour utiliser pour une
utilisation maxime optimale de votre
service est ce que vous préconisez qu'il
y est
collaboration entre profs élèves et
parents ou bien on laisse on donne un
peu plus d'autonomie à l'enfant quand il
fait ses révisions à travers le prof
qu'est ce que vous préconisez tous les
paramètres de l'âge de l'enfant onde
valoriser davantage d'autonomie
c'est certain mais la présence du
parrain quand même très important
on essaie de donner beaucoup de pression
sur les épaules des parents aussi parce
que c'est comme ça aujourd'hui et les
paramètres en général pas mal de
pression et des fois ça va aller jusqu'à
réaliser le travail à la place de
l'enfant pour être ça veut dire ils sont
assez peu efficace il faut l'entendre
l'enseignant ylvanie davantage de
parents aux idées alors c'est vraiment
un ticket chez les parents mais dès
qu'ils sont les encourager et leur
montrer des ressources comme un autre
mais cultivent mans c'est vraiment mieux
quand c'est l'enfant qui prend sangliers
qui volent humain sa démarche et les
rendre autonomes les enfants parce que
ses débuts oui oui tu te fais c'est
l'objectif je voulais à l'examen enfin
il est tout seul 8 peut-être des niveaux
pouvoir se fier à certaines ressources
et peut-être droit sans téléphone doit
savoir chercher
c'est ce à quoi il faut faut pas se fier
au téléphone ce père de famille qui n'a
pas trouvé le profil ah ouais mais c'est
google qui a les algorithmes de google
c'est une autre histoire chez moi
j'entends la la cloche sonne et c'est la
fête de la période
alors ceux qui étaient là dessus merci
beaucoup nous avoir montré la place de
lovecraft
c'est fantastique pour vendredi à
l'école de foot alors c'est à vous andré
tanguay directeur relations extérieures
et stratégies aux profs au sein
d'organismes depuis 18 ans il les fait
pas alors écoutez
à aller vers la grosse non à ce que l'on
va vers la grosse boule où on va aller
vers la grosse voix il y avait beaucoup
de boue la perdre encore une fois
j'adore ça 30 bull et moi moi je suis
des jeunes ils ont leurs 90 alors 30
ball à perdre présente la deuxième
question de cette grosse boule vous
aujourd'hui
selon le national en titre association
c'est aux états unis où l'on aille mais
combien de minutes
en principe les devoirs devrait-il avoir
en moyenne à partir du secondaire
c'est important à partir du secondaire
si on se fie aux amériques
qu'est ce que ça donne est-ce que ce re
devrait se fie à 10 minutes de devoir
par jour ça c'est à la réponse a est ce
que ça devrait être 20 minutes par jour
est ce que c'est c'est 30 minutes par
jour
ou est ce que c'est des 60 minutes par
jour à partir de la première année du
secondaire jean les six premières années
puisque les américains soient prêts pour
le dvd
non non je suis en train de réfléchir à
haute voix en colombie pour le d alors
parler à haute voix ces trente minutes
pas plus moi je serais d'accord avec ce
choix peut encore moi moi j'allais à la
dure comme samir 68 america l'élection
sont au maximum
je pense que mouss passé une très
mauvaise expérience avec les devoirs
quand j'ai car j'avais 15 ans parce que
je revenais de l'école le temps du super
temps suite à cette heure le soir tu
plongeaient dans les plans 2 jusqu'à 9
ans avait reçu chez moi je pensais
pouvoir en plusieurs parts soit
longtemps au secondaire
la bonne réponse ça devrait être quoi
exactement sont les américains noirs
américains ouais selon les américains
si c'est des démocrates ou six cd
est-ce que c'est sexy mais ne passait
pas seven qui déboule 20 minutes là mais
ça pour faire des sauts aux primaires
première année du primaire
vous avez quel âge en première année 11
à 12 secondes de retard ses 12 ans qui
joue un peu d'avancé 10 ans comme 20
minutes
enfin les minutes ont s'asseoir balisé
crayon ni cherche des formations en plus
maintenant le téléphone c'est un
concurrent à devoir c'est les tablettes
et les téléphones sont des concurrents
après toutes ces années d'expérience je
me dis si pas l'important ce n'est pas
de savoir quelque chose d'essayer de
savoir comment le savoir oui d'ailleurs
comme en échec comment chercher
l'information c'était ça le devienne l
appellation entre ce qui était l'homo
sapiens l'homme qui sait ok et
aujourd'hui le mot sapiens sapiens 6
l'homme qui sait qu'ils avaient aidé par
essence et être président des états unis
débat est là la bad opinion personnelle
à cette émission concernant l'incident
exposés bon on y va avec
qu'est-ce que j'ai d'autres comme
surprise aujourd'hui au si ça vous
intéresse de continuer votre découverte
du système d'éducation canadiens les
devoirs tout ça je vous propose la vidéo
numéro 6 c'est ce que nos internautes
peuvent voir qui est affichée en même
temps que le son et l'image de cette
émission alors jeu on appelle ça la paix
soit la page web de tam-tam canada
regardons ensemble vidéo de 0,6 cette
semaine tout est tentante pour une fois
là tout est en vous ce que fin j'ai fait
le ménage alors la jemaye reproduction
ercis on aurait pu la sas et moi
production c découvrez nos archives sur
le même sujet voilà et qui est capable
de lire lips ling de plus en plus
populaire
allô prof devient-il maintenant
essentiel doit élire à vos enfants avant
l'âge de 2 ans veut dire éventuellement
une rive sud scolaire haute idée de voir
au fond l'éducation à des niveaux plus
avancés réduit l'écart salarial
enfin nous dire à quel point des élèves
québécois sont les meilleurs en
mathématiques au pays et il y avait une
suite mais oui ça fait quatre ans que
c'est comme ça c'est vrai là si vous
cliquez sur un autre dossier ça
s'appelle que devriez-vous savoir
l'indication au canada qu'on nous sommes
jamais enseigné vous pouvez en apprendre
des entrevues à tout casser c'est un
auditeur quelque part dans le monde nous
a posé une question et on n'y a répondu
je sors sur tam-tam canada cette semaine
une à écouter il a le plaisir c'est
qu'on fait on fait le tour pour voir
combien de bouli reste vous avez tous
temps de la deuxième manche aura perdu
quand on a perdu 30 donc dans la suite à
70 7 5 tonnes non j'avais perdu vers
début oui j'ai perdu train d'enclencher
à 5 ans voilà c'est un troisième jeu il
ya là combien à perdre
55 ans donc vous pourriez vous retrouver
c'est un gagnant allégé de toutes ces
boules sur le dialogue des frères la
troisième question la fiche à l'écran
troisième question c'est long il ya pas
seulement les devoirs mais aussi le
nombre de joueurs il faut passer à
l'école dans lequel de ces pays l'année
scolaire était la plus longue en ce
moment françois israël j'irai france
israël ou c'est brésil où des canada
brésil il ya beaucoup de soleil je pas
si on passe beaucoup de jours comme ça à
l'école plutôt pas la placer au canada
se réjouit 682 joue souviens parce que
les vacances ici c'est vraiment
strictement de moi moi je connais des
pays où ça va trois mois qu'elle moi
quand j'étais à aux primaires pour moi
les vacances étaient trois mois mais
moins billes à gérer par exemple c'était
trois mois à l'époque en princesse qui
vont pas à l'école aussi le samedi bison
le vendredi le conseil a par un long
temps installé jeu
jeudi dimanche à dakar à la maintenance
et les cinq jours alors l'année scolaire
la plus longue mais je dire israël
israël pour raymond alors moi je dis moi
je dirais canada canada où l'alors
canada parce qu'il fait froid l'hiver
hausse mais reste à l'école parce que
parce que y'a pas y'a pas trop 2 c'est
pas moi je vais devant la france
j'espère avoir accès c'est différent
franchement il ya que le brésil qui a
pas été sélectionné au canada moi je
suis français
votre réponse à israël voilà voilà
et on voit la vraie mangani 219 jours
par année c'est sa voix s'élèvent à ce
paradoxe et le canada 180 bain ou si
vous faisiez 880 j'ai failli m'étouffer
180 287 aux états unis deux sens et par
exemple ex-aequo japonais australiens
danois italiens mexicain brésilien ou
six à la fin c'est plus que ça la france
écoutez je la 260 262 seulement et au
canada à 82 ans il faut entendre les
dieux il sera l on va répéter la leçon
parce que les étudiants n'écoute pas
elle s'était 200 219 2 c'est la france à
260 270 cv 180 jours répartis
essentiellement 180 180 2 selon le ces
six mois ces six mois s'est étalé sur 9
km
voilà la décence pour ça que j'ai envie
agen qui a perdu des boules ben moi je
pense que mouna m'en restait plus
d'accord qui a perdu des boules
ils m'ont vraiment qu'ils gagnent alors
je m'engage avec 60 et 70 le seul
nouveau sur renault
je ne prends cher ami avec humilité je
tenterai de respecter la qualité de
votre travail
[Rires]
spécialiste du violon écoutez vous
pouvez me dire quelle est l'image cette
semaine vous aussi de l epa attentive en
place pour écouter c'est un vendredi
quand je réponds par où les limaces
nord-américain tardons pas ce que c'est
noir américain c'est nord amérique
est-ce que c'est l'ouragan denrées en ce
sens dans sa tête rien ne vient jamais
vous ça a quelque chose à voir avec leur
vie lorient le docteur d'aller avec la
ds qui était si beau bahamas les et la
bâtisse était sur le bateau mais c'est
pas ça c'est aux nouvelles c'est ce qui
s'en vient chez nous c'est ce qui s'en
vient chez nous en nouvelle écosse et ça
pourrait être ça la semaine prochaine sa
frappe est lié la canadienne qu'il est
décédé à dents non non non mais tout est
lié
mais il ya un élément commun ya un fil
blanc réchauffement climatique sont en
piscine une politique ancien passent en
alabama non ça pense pas là bas bravo
félicitations
oui y'a pas quelqu'un qui est un gros
feutre noir
le président a qui disent ah oui ça va
vous faut toucher ça va pas du tout
alors qu'elle n'a pas très bien sa
géographie
on aurait été content que ça passe sur
deux là bas parce que je ne serais pas
venu chez nous mais l'a écouté sa volon
salon de la côte cassée des carradine de
prison voilà lancé voilà la preuve
scientifique quant à la maison blanche
que ç'a failli passer sur l'alabama
évidemment ça c'est beaucoup plus
sérieux c'est ce qui se passait là c'est
ce qui devrait être vraiment qu'après
toute l'attention c'est obama c'est la
grave et là parce que vous savez que si
les bahamas et un chapelet d'îles qui a
des yeux qui ont pas du tout et et oui
il y en a d'autres qui ont été gravement
touchés je ne sais pas si j'ai lu ça
dans les photos ça c'est un diaporama
conçu par sybille si je dis à ces
bicyclettes ailleurs je pense que j'ai
inclus une image qui représente lille
le principal avant et après je pas sûr
que je les jeux les ajouté avez vous vu
cette image là vous avez pas vu un
c'est incroyable ça il reste plus que 40
% du territoire non inondée cette fin de
semaine parce que j'ai trouvé incroyable
c'est de voir les aéroports qui était
complètement synergies on ne voyait pas
du tout les pistes et après seulement
comment pour pouvoir rebâtir
si je serai là pour que l'avion puisse
atterrir et en plus pour que l'année
prochaine il y aura probablement un
autre c'est ça il ya eu une autre image
qui circulent et j'ai vu ce matin quatre
événements météorologiques majeurs
quatre ouragans ou tempête la dame qui
ceinturent l'océan pacifique atlantique
en ce moment dont deux rien évidemment
alors il montrait son image vous dis que
c'est pas unique on a déjà vu ça en 2015
mais à l'image est saisissante là ça
ressemble ces géants ces histoires voilà
en parlant de propos de g en jeu faisait
pas allusion à tremble pas sur écoute et
c'est tout est ce que vous voulez
ajouter quelque chose de pouvoir encore
posé des questions avant la fin du coup
moi j'aimais bien à l'école
ouais c'est intéressant à prendre au jeu
contre un pull
non mais mais mais les parents sont de
nos jours ils sont vraiment confrontés à
la concurrence des de l'exotique ils
sont c'est vraiment c'est un certain
challenge vous deviez la maison tout à
fait donc ses règles réglé après règles
appliquées et puis dès qu'on relâche un
peu tout tour reprend merci beaucoup
raymond merci merci beaucoup
samir merci stéphane merci et maryse
malgré tout la perte de vos boules et
bien venir notre nouveau se faire au lot
[Musique]